and checking in on the trump campaign
tonight the president's spending his
final day campaigning in key
battleground states
north carolina pennsylvania michigan and
wisconsin
jesse tenor joining us now live tonight
from washington and boy it was a busy
day
jesse what is the the president's
message tonight to those voters in those
important states
yeah good evening president trump
definitely made the final case for
another four years really talking about
the coronavirus pandemic since that's
obviously
on a lot of voters minds going into
election day tomorrow
he was saying that another four years
would ensure that a vaccine hits the
market quickly
and it would be safe and effective which
would then continue to stimulate the
economy and then he countered it by
saying that
a biden administration would lead to
more lockdowns across the country which
would then
hurt the economy biden's campaign has of
course continued to push back on this
even today at rallies of his own
where he criticized the president's
handling of the pandemic
but the president knows that this is an
important topic to really hit voters on
since we are seeing from 2016 to 2020
some of that solid base that he had the
suburban
rural and white voters kind of start
going toward biden
and then president trump needing to pick
up those
first-time voters and americans who
haven't voted in quite some time
i know you've been on the beat for a
while president trump earlier as saying
that
as soon as election day ends quote we're
going in with our lawyers end quote
any idea if you're looking into your
crystal ball what potential voting
challenges we might see in the days
ahead
[Music]
it's seeming like the first one that we
could see is yet another challenge to
the pennsylvania voting and the u.s
supreme court has already handed down
two decisions on that so where
technically where it stands right now is
that the state can continue to
count those mail-in ballots up to three
days after election day
republicans are still trying to
challenge that and so president trump
indicated that he's ready he called that
supreme court decision throughout the
day today and even tweeting about it he
called it very dangerous
and saying that it would even incite
violence in the streets
um of course people have been people on
the other side have continued to push
back on that
biden was even saying today at his
rallies that the president cannot
determine the election
that you know that the country won't let
him
do that that it's not set up that way
but
like the president indicated he is very
ready for these legal challenges and we
could see
more in more states in days to come
setting up for a long day tomorrow and a
long week all right jesse tinor joining
us now live from washington night thank
you